each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
today we have Ganesh listening us from
mr. Washington extremely glad that he
could make this a descriptive or he went
to rpi he graduated from you know animal
university in 1997 de degree and they
are ma degree from University of Texas
in 2002 and after he joined you mr.
Washington big hit lab he worked with
Professor Blake on updates and he's just
completed his doctoral work and will be
going to rpi today he is going to give
us a description and a presentation on
his doctor work with that good afternoon
everyone so my talk is going to be based
on my dissertation work but I'm quite
trying to kind of outline the talk such
that it's much more it covers all the
aspects and later on if you have any
specific questions I can delve into all
the details one of the first thing I
would want to tell us when you can we
interact with computers we have voice
recognition vision through the monitor
you can have virtual reality goggles but
one of the interesting aspects that is
missing is touch in a day to day life
touches very very important like the
firm handshake or a hug so touch plays a
vital role so my primary research is
from haptics which is which is a science
of force feedback and I am particularly
interested in networked a haptic virtual
environments so why do we need that you
know in the present age of globalization
so you could have multiple peoples
working on a project situated around the
globe or even across the United States
and it is often gets really difficult to
bring everyone in one place
to get to make descend these decisions
you could do is what you can have a like
a teleconference or video conference
where people can interact but then it
would be really ideal if you have a
virtual reality systems where the users
can actually interact in the application
there are certain application that
requires force feedback to get the
maximum ultimate experience of course it
can be combined with audio and video so
it is not only it is not a standalone
application itself but it's an argument
it can augment the existing systems some
of the applications that includes
surgical training maintenance procedure
training also one of the important
aspect will be the network haptic games
right now the gaming technologies lack
in terms of force feedback so it also
applicable to gaining so i can give you
kind of a whole watch the basic idea
began low if we consider a very simple
task right to users are just replacing a
in screen and then this this involves
two users just one 1 user 2 users have
to bear the weight and then hold it in
place so it's just not only visual but
it also involves lot of haptic kicks and
if you want to Train somebody else to do
this task and if you want to do a
virtual reality environment to do this
it would be best only if you have a
haptic feedback there are there are
existing systems like cave and other
virtual reality systems where you can
have a totally immersive environment but
if they lacked force feedback so the
other aspect would be is even though
this is a very very simple application
you can also consider another another
one where for example in industrial
setting there is an accident then you
have to be transported in a stretcher so
the two users or two-person have to
carry
in a structure over the complicated
Starbase or through some industrial
setting so you can also train your
workforce on like contingencies without
having them experience that in
completely in a virtual reality setting
so the inverse cases you might want to
feel the force of lifting somebody on
the stretcher that you don't have to
imagine so in those applications force
feedback also is very critical as far as
I said when I said force feedback and
virtual reality expressions there is
also situations where the experts could
be located in a different place or even
a different office yoga are
geographically different location and
then all the users could be in different
place but experts can always join in in
the simulation over the long distance
and then participate in this virtual
reality simulation with in that case
network both the virtual environments of
networks so they're my research is
directly applicable so also when I say
it's applicable to games I want to point
out that I've been working on haptics
for five years so actually I have my own
haptic device the technology as us come
to a point where you can get a device
for two hundred dollars on is called
Norvin Falcon and then it you can
actually play games with it so for
example you can use do bowling you can
feel the weight of the ball then you can
push it so the momentum acceleration
force they all you can it's like a
physically-based but you also totally
involvement because you have the
complete force feedback so I also want
to point out one thing is that imagine a
situation where people are designing
aircraft parts in a solidworks model and
then you want to that you have to make a
design decision okay I need to place
this fire detector here but then the
fire detector needs maintenance like
every n number of hours of flight flight
hours we do not want to put that in
somewhere more complicated place that
you
need to remove or move through so many
different parts to reach that right
because that is not good you want to do
it in a minimal disturbance like you
want to go get access to the part that
needs maintenance and get out so you so
in that case you have to design that
right so you can you can just log into
your solidworks you can under the other
user maybe is situated in Tokyo or
Boston or anywhere they could log in at
the same time you both can collaborate
in the same virtual space and then make
this design decisions but of course
unlike just virtual reality applications
which are very passive like even even
like one of the things is like watching
a video right you are downloading the
video from the server and watching it so
you there is lot of adaptive process
goes on and then you actually see the
video but then it is totally passive in
the sense the only way you interact with
them you see through your vision but
when I say force feedback you actually
physically connect some part of your
body to the device and then you're
moving it right then you experience the
force feedback so there is a human in
the loop which are actively engaged and
then there is a continuous energy that
is transmitted so stability is like one
of the key thing you don't want the
device to suddenly go like 20 Newton's
of force on you and then your hands you
don't want to play that much force on
your hand suddenly so there is lot of
careful design consideration that goes
into designing such a system on one of
the key is when I say networks people in
Seattle another another person
collaborating in Boston we had to
overcome the network latency so there is
the minimums latency depending on the
speed of light which we cannot do
anything about so your system has to be
capable of coping with latency and also
if you use internet right the regular
internet is not only you are getting
fixed alert and see but also there is a
jitter your delay is going to vary quite
a bit and of course you can lose
information right and then oftentimes
your bandwidth might be restricted
and so these are the some of the key
things that your system should be
resilient against or you should design
system such that it it shouldn't affect
by all these factors and then one of the
key thing was out to maintain coherence
in the simulation as I said when I when
I want I I gave several examples gaming
and then one of the example is having
this CAD model where people want to
collaborate on this virtual prototyping
or maintenance task so my research is
primarily focused on the second
application which is having
collaborative haptics application for
cad modeling unser related application
and one of them is also surgery training
where you absolutely need to maintain
coherence in the simulation or later
tell what am I mean by coherency so it's
not very interesting when you have a
network system it could be connected in
two days one is like centralized or
distributed on other terminologies
client server or the pH beer I'm going
to talk about it a little bit later but
then the old problem space of network
haptic virtual environment in involves
lot of factors one of them is force
range so for example if you are using
gaming right often often you might want
to experience Willy impulse force like
you're playing a table tennis or a ping
pong game yep so you're explaining every
demand the ball it's your bat you
experience of impulsive force and then
there is no force after that so the
design for those and the force criteria
are very different whereas if you are
moving a big object in a virtual
environment right you made the
experience continuous force larger
amount of force so the force range is
one of the criteria and the error
tolerance as I mentioned for virtual
prototyping and surgical simulations you
might want to minimize the error as much
as possible irrespective of where the
users are error has to be minimum
whereas in gaming it's ok I mean even if
the error is large you can always
counteract because or more often you are
experiencing for spurning momentarily
there is no continuous force feedback
and then there is the aspect of mobility
you know like in CAD applications it is
often you can restrict the user to move
slowly or because they are doing some
very delicate objects trying to locate
place an object inside this LexA part of
the wing or placing this fire detector
where are in gaming right if you go if
you move favor and move slow you're
going to lose points you got to move
anywhere in the virtual space get an
object and things like that so mobility
is important and also dexterity which
are related for you don't for like
surgical simulation application or
prototyping you need eyelid dexterous
manipulation and then also the degrees
of freedom so you might want to
experience six degrees of freedom often
because torque is an important aspect in
mechanical things but in gaming you can
get away with just one degree or two
degrees of freedom also computational
complexity is one thing that we really
need to keep track of you do not want to
build a system then you need a like a
big server or some huge computational
power to run your system it might want
to run in a simple pc or a cluster small
group of cluster so i have i have
decided in terms of graph i chose three
three applications one is entertainment
by gaining predominantly like optics for
gaming applications then I have I had to
delicate task which I am interested one
is the surgery training another is a
virtual assembly task which related to
care and then I have applauded some of
the criteria that I spoke on for example
for a force feedback right so in surgery
often the forces are low because if you
are experiencing too much first then you
are really damaging the tissues so you
do not really put too much force but but
in CAD assembly task often you might
want to do apply a lot of force to
complete a task in gaming it varies
depending upon what what type of gaming
you choose as well as if you see the
gaming also
requires really high mobility whereas
other the virtual assembly task and
surgery training we can it needs a low
mobility is fine as well as the error
tolerance should be really low for this
task so similarly the way I spoke talked
of this few points here i protect the
delay versus bandwidth you do not want
to design a game that occupies very
large bandwidth because you want people
to use their dsl connection or at home
and play games you don't want them to
have a very expensive internet
connection whereas the virtual
prototyping of subjugating often
involves in your university or bigger
companies they have the luxury or the a
they have the capability to get really
dedicated internet connections so they
can have like large bandwidth similarly
I have the thought that the
computational complexity on versus
degrees of freedom the worst dexterity
so if you see that both the surgical
training task in virtual assembly task
all this lies in higher degrees of
freedom as well as hired dexterous
manipulation so I am primarily focused
on task in this block where it I
dexterous as well as high degree of
freedom but basically low error and
tolerant that was one of my primary
criteria so in order whenever I talk
about coherency in this stock I there is
a very particular definition further is
for example if the users are
manipulating a virtual object so the
user in Seattle as some as the virtual
object in a screen as well as the user
say in Boston so there are two copies of
the same virtual objects so my criteria
is to minimize error between the two
copies if I minimize the error then
there is always a covariance see in the
simulation because I know exactly when I
move the object on or the person
experiencing or seeing on the screen in
Boston is also doing the same thing so
there is I out minimize there're so that
is why it took the position covariance
has a very important criteria I also
want to do
can a single instant of global temp it
pretty easy to do like you can use you
can you can almost synchronize your
clocks is using ntp or gps so that you
can all always maintain perfect cross
synchronization between do computers and
then when you send packet information
you can timestamp is so it is very easy
to maintain covalency and also maintain
time relevance so why am I very
interested in that so I'm just giving a
very very simple example imagine like
there is a CAD object right and then
most of the time the object will have
broader with but then there may be areas
where the width is very trying right it
may be like point three millimeters
point two millimeters like you can have
clean objects so the imagine the two
users are moving an object right so
whatever you are seeing is actually what
you one person is seeing in the virtual
environment on this copy of this the
virtual object right so this is the thin
wall then the user one on is located in
say in Boston user to is located in
Seattle so if you do not maintain
coherency right the user on this side in
boston they could go on this side of the
wall another user on this side can in
seattle can go on to this side of the
wall because the wall is so thin if you
do not maintain the coherency then you
can end up in 22 in the two copies of
the simulation like the virtual
environment will end up into two
different sides of the thin wall and
then when you want to synchronize one
way to do is oh you know what the
virtual objects are or two different
location I want to make my objective is
minimize error so i can make it zero the
error is 0 but then if since is a
physically based model you cannot just
penetrate through the wall like
sometimes if you play multiplayer games
you can see sometimes objects disappear
appeared through the wall or like in
device basically physical principles but
you cannot do it with haptic feedback
because you cannot penetrate this wall
because it is a rigid
however thin edges so you so you have to
maintain the coherency in the simulation
so this is which gives like a more
convincing example this is a typical CAD
part of aircraft model like where is a
very very small snapshot so it involves
lot of tubes and pipes and things so I
my research was funded by Boeing so with
the courtesy of going and able to show
this simple snapshot and you can see if
if if a to users are manipulating and
moving an object inside this virtual
space you don't want the end up being
one side of the tube or the other side
of a tube or other side of the wall so
you might want to maintain the coherency
cliente simulation and then the two
users can take this object maybe play
sit here and say oh we know what which
is the best way to take it to there
should be cross all these cables or if
there is too many cables to cross maybe
we should put this year so it is easier
for the maintenance people to go and
access the doctor so those kind of
design decisions could be made with an
haptic device on using the CAD models as
a virtual environment so now I come back
to the the first part of the talk when I
said about the network haptic virtual
environment can be classified into
client-server and peer-to-peer I am very
interested in peer-to-peer or
distributed architecture because it is
completely scalable I can scale and then
each period can multicast the
information to every other peer so that
you can you can involve large number of
peers in the simulation whereas in
client server is you cannot you might
need to multiple servers are you really
going to overload the server so i am
very interested in first to answer this
article aberration possible using a
distributed architecture so that or most
of my system of work is based on
distributed architecture but i also use
the client-server architecture to
compare the distributive scheme to see
how well they compare but
if you remember when I said go ahead and
see right client server is the best
method to maintain coherency because the
server maintains the master copy of all
the virtual object so each client query
the server on server gives the current
position of the virtual object so always
there is one location where the master
copy of the autumn virtually all the
positions are maintained so in that way
maintaining coherence is much more
relevant and easier in client server but
then if the client has to work with the
server he has to first send the
information to the server server sensory
information back to the client so you
have to do a round trip delay so it is
almost if the the delay is in
milliseconds one way you have to and
milliseconds before you actually various
the new position whereas in peer-to-peer
since each period is multi casting the
information right so each period gets
current information in n milliseconds of
other peers location if everyone is
located in milliseconds apart also in
client-server if say if client three is
is located further apart like he has the
maximum delay then he unnecessarily he
will delay the entire simulation or if
the client one is located right in the
server or very close to server the
client one have any one unique advantage
because you can interact with the server
and realize position much faster than
the client three so you cannot maintain
equality like you do not want ideally
you would want all the plans to feel the
same thing so those are the drawbacks of
using client-server scheme so here I
outline the three virtual coupling
schemes I kind of outline in the in the
diagram that is kind of a very standard
or easy to understand in in terms of
haptics community because it involves
both mechanical aspect to it so I can
walk you through to understand this
diagram is pretty easy in the sense of
course communication channel is no need
explanation it is like it could
internet or local network or anything on
they are time varying delay and then if
you see the object Oh 1100 and to those
are the virtual copies of the object
that users are interacting so there is
only one object but to right now it
shows only two user multi-user
environment so the object 11 and 12 or
the two copies of the same object under
user one is located here is interacting
locally with this virtual object user to
is locally interacting with this virtual
object and also if you see the virtual
objects between themselves are connected
by a spring and damper so you can
imagine this as copies of the two
virtual objects but they are connected
by a spring damper so when you push one
object other object would move ideally
if you have an infinite stiffness rate
then whenever you move it will track
exactly so that is the concept begin in
one and also this is the peer-to-peer
scheme because you can have three users
for users and ask on you you had to
scale the number of the springs and
dampers that you cannot be doing the
virtual objects and there is a there is
a nice terminology for the for this they
are called virtual couplings because
they are not a real spring and damper
but they are like they exist
computationally so they are called
virtual couplings but they actually
couple between the virtual copies of the
object so in this way you can maintain
covariance see in the simulation because
I can tune this springs and dampers
parameters so that position error
between object / and 12 or minimize so I
can always design the system such that
the error is minimized right this is one
way to do the peer-to-peer system the
second virtual coupling i am showing is
is disappeared to peer system again but
it's slightly different in the sense
each user as this one copy of the
virtual object but then
each user's position is transmitted
across the network say so if I am the
user I transmit my position across the
network then if the other user on their
side they use the virtual object and
then use current position on the
position that obtained using the network
and then they calculate force locally
similarly the user to does the same
thing on this side you know so the
connection is through the if you see
this is the haptic handle so this this
represents the haptic angle in the
virtual environment so the users
position is connected so as to as long
as as long as two users maintain contact
with the object right because I am
touching this object right and then
there is a copy of the same object in
other user is also maintaining contact
so there is this continuous loop from
this contact through this object and
through this contact to that object
there is a continuous loop so this two
virtual objects will track each other
and if this is applicable only when you
have to maintain contact so in some
applications like in especially in CAD
applications you you actually take an
object move into a space and hole and
put it in some other location in those
situation you always maintain continuous
contact so in certain applications it is
directly applicable the third one is the
client server so assess when I said the
server as the copy of the virtual
objects and server maintains a master
copy right if you see here in the client
server this is the server and then to
make the matters much much more
simplified the user one is located in
the server the user to is the client who
experiences a delay so if you see the
you there is what there is only one copy
of the object which exists in the server
user one since he is already locally
connected to the server he experienced
immediate force feedback through this
virtual coupling but the user to is the
client right he could be safe
situated in Boston every time any asked
to experience force feedback he has to
send the oppose his position across the
network to the server and then server
does the collision detection and
calculates whoa based on the two users
position this is the new updated
position once that is done the server
sends the position new position back to
the client right but if you see there is
a local virtual coupling and I have
shown the virtual object just as a
position because if if I am a client
even though I see a complete virtual
object on my side and I am interacting
with it its position does not go in to
change until the new position is updated
through the network from the server so
Fred some time pushing this object I can
push as hard as I want but until my
position is sent to the server and the
server updates a position it is not
updated so but the book so that is why
he explains the force feedback locally
through this position constraint but the
good thing about this is if the if the
client is delayed so much like it takes
60 milliseconds to send the information
to the server so it takes 120
milliseconds for the new position to
arrive in the 120 milliseconds you if
you do not give a immediate local force
feedback loop you could go into unstable
situations so in my design there is this
local virtual coupling give I impedance
path for the user so the user always
experienced a local force feedback until
new updated information comes from the
server so this is kind of the mechanical
perspective of the scheme's if some
people are very interested in control
perspective they want to see in terms of
discrete-time models and then I actually
have a slides later on if you are really
interested to see those system I can
talk about it later because basically
all the systems I all the three
commercial coupling schemes I showed
here or basically a multi-input
multi-output systems you can have very
formal control perspective shoot
so basically these three virtual
couplings which are two are peer to peer
and one is client-server and I know
client server is really good for
maintaining position coherency so my
idea my objective is to test these three
schemes under various conditions and
then see how well the distributed scheme
compares to the client server scheme or
the central ice cream and then I want to
see whether we can man whether we can
have a haptic collaboration using a
distributed architecture so in order to
do that of course when I said I have to
do it in a stable region because when
you interact with the haptic device you
have a direct energy interaction so that
when you are the energy interaction you
do not want the system to go unstable so
I achieve my system to be really act in
a stable region then I want I tested my
system in a first a constant delay which
gives the baseline standard then a time
varying delay when I said time varying
delay like the internet so i used the
actual internet and did global scale
internet experiments at multi rate why i
am interested in multi rate because for
for feeling really hot objects differ
objects' you need to maintain update
rate at thousand Hertz which is thousand
times per second imagine you are sending
UDP packets or thousand times per second
of certain fixed size the quickly going
to ocupe lot of bandwidth and the
bandwidth not all the users might have
the luxury of having that that much
bandwidth so that I'd multirate i can
send the transmission at hundred Hertz
or 500 Hertz or like only every tenth
packet is sent to the other user in that
case i want i tested my system at multi
rate so i can also objectively tell how
the system perform at various
transmission rate also i am very
interested to see is like to i once i
present the results and things somebody
comes and say oh you know what you were
experimental results involve this kind
of network and this network is like
research research network they are
bigger
network what what if I have to see the
exceed my system how the system
performance for a say low bandwidth dsl
type of connection so for that I do not
later on i will say how i did my
internet bit experiment so it would be
really good if you have an emulated in
your lab so you can tune the emulator to
create various Network conditions and
then you can test the system so as a
third part i also did did the experiment
with local network emulators and then I
I have some results on that later on I
am NOT going to really talk in detail
about this because it is purely a
controlled perspective but time delay
compensation is a very important aspect
when I said the network applications
have continuous energy transmission so i
said i tune my parameter so that my
system is stable you can also design
your system such that they are
asymptotically stable you know like
irrespective of whatever the time delay
is still your system is going to be
stable so there are already common time
delay compensation techniques that
existing teleoperation on the good thing
about my peer-to-peer scheme is it is
exactly like a tell your operation
system so i can use this compensation
techniques in my system and then i can
analyze the system performance so in
order to come up with an objective
criteria and answers you want to
simplify as much as he could if you have
hundreds of knobs and if you start
tuning all the snobs you do not know
which one which is a right not to set it
to get the system results so first i
simplified such that my system is only
one degree of freedom and then my
virtual environment is very simple it is
just as a one virtual object which is a
cube right and then the two users are
used to run and user to this is the
screenshot of the user one's perspective
this is what user one sees in a screen
you said to would see the same thing in
the screen in or in this compute
monitor another objective is to track
this target the target will move from
center to the left and then left to the
right and back to the center so you have
to track this target so the target moves
at a fixed speed which is really slow
one point three three millimeters per
second as I said initially there are the
problem space is really big you mean you
can have really I mobility application
but I am NOT interested in that I am
interesting much more dexterous but low
mobility application so it's still fine
if you move on at that slower speed and
then the cube is 30 millimeters with on
the target is 20 millimeters the user
one and user tube will will will will be
making contact with the virtual object
so initially the cube will be white in
color as soon as the user touches the
virtual object and then when they apply
the force and if their force exceeds 10
percent of the maximum recommended value
which is 3.2 Newton's for the haptic
device are used the the color of the
cube will tend to blue the idea being
that the two users are actively engaging
in the experiment so for example you
could give you you might get bored very
well I have seen during experiments
sometimes subjects get really bored so
they might take the contact away or or
they can make a contact but then they do
not put any effort to push the virtual
object so in this case when the force
exceeds 10 percent of the recommended
value the color changes for blue so I
recommend my subjects that during the
experiments the color of the cube should
be always maintained blue the other
aspect is when the force exceeds three
point in newtons which is the maximum
recommended force for the phantom Omni
device that I use the color of the cube
will turn to read so i will tell me
subjects when the color turns to red
that means you are experienced you are
exceeding too much force so push gently
so sometimes it might end up that they
cannot track the target that well so i
also
design the software architecture for the
center collaborative haptic system so
basically it involves two standalone
applications I have a front end for
graphics on user interface so i used the
QT because I develop applications are
across windows and linux platform so i
want something which can run on
cross-platform so i used cutie as my
friend turn and then the QT maintains
the graphics and it updates the graphics
and then the haptic controller part
which is a standalone C++ application
which maintains the optic controller
which maintains all the haptic
interaction and there is large more
information is available in the slide or
don't want to go in depth for each block
but basically it supports both bins or
under Berkeley socket so you can just
compile in a Windows environment and
then use it so user is not restricted by
any particular operating system also if
you see that the graphics application
the graphics update to the front the
interface is through TCP connection
because you graphics you need to update
the graphics or 30 Hertz it is enough if
you updated 30 girls so even for those
low update rates you can update through
a TCP connection whereas my haptic
controller the haptic data or
transmitted a thousand Hertz and then I
also did that five hundred and hundred
Hertz so in those cases I cannot really
handle TCP using TCP tcp/ip so I use UDP
for the communication between appears on
the between server and the clients so
when I said global scale optic
collaboration I have this dilemma when I
started my research I wanted to test in
a realistic network I am varying delay
network but it would be really it will
be really interesting news article or
something if I actually collaborate with
somebody say situated somewhere in
Europe or something I can tell him oh
why don't you come on this time let's
collaborate and collect data but then
you imagine there is like a tenth of
hours or so
difference they began to different time
zone either i have to come really early
morning into the lab or yes to stay back
really late so it all the it gets really
complex to then human subjects study if
if you have subjects spread across the
continents so ideally I want to build a
system so that all the human subjects
will be located in the same laboratory
and then so that they all in the same
lab in the same of space so I can
control all the aspects of the
experiment equally among the subjects at
the same time they also can experience
realistic network conditions so what I
did is of course in the robotics
community always have peers and friends
so cover many people will came forward
unwilling to host a small program in the
server so i opened a particular port UDP
port and then they run this simple
reflector program that i wrote so that
every time when the two subjects have to
do the experiments right in sometimes
they are connected locally within the
lab and other times their packets are
routed through the internet through
these various reflectors and this is
what you see like between see I I add
one in North Carolina State University
another is in pontedera Italy which is a
university called scala superior a
sundowner on the unday the packets go
through very different research networks
within the US it goes to national lambda
rail and then I have a packet reflector
hosted in the university of british
columbia ubc so they have a canary is
canadian research network and similar to
the research network in US Europe also
as research Network so if you are
interested I can later give you the
trace route to see how these packets are
routed is very interesting and then
another quite an interesting thing this
the server was a windows machine in UBC
unveil it was a Mac machine and then in
pointing the rate was a linux so I are
three different flavors on this
so this keeps a very pictorial view of
all the experiments are there is always
two subjects in my experiment user 1 and
user too and then they sit in the same
lab and they do the experiment and then
depending on the network condition
depending on the conditions that that
during the experiments the packets are
routed all through the internet so they
experience real internet network
conditions so this is just a snapshot
during one of the subject study so user
one is always me I am the experimenter
user to is what I XP recruit different
subjects and then they do use human
subject is a basically human subject
study we evaluate the performance but if
you see they both we both are located in
the same lab just are just opposite desk
so I can start the experiment and stop
the experiment I can even communicate
with them in real life you cannot really
communicate with pursue initially unless
they have a phone or something so I'm
not going to go in detail on how I did
my experiments and stuff because it will
be really interesting for people who do
lot of human subject experiments always
the user one is me I am the experimenter
and then user to is recruited subjects
usually it's part of the University of
Washington students staff and faculty
and then always the objective is to
track the target it is a one degree of
freedom task they are they track the
target and then I I vary the number of
trials and delay conditions and packet
transmission rate based on what
experiment I am doing and then I am also
testing image remember i am also testing
the three schemes to peer-to-peer scheme
and one client server scheme so all the
schemes delay and transmission rate are
all randomized and then during the
experiment randomly those those things
are applied so the user would never know
what they what they are doing they
always do the just the task they are
asked to do and then I I add 10 subjects
for each experiment I did like four up
to faience five to six experiments for
my research one way to look at the
ask is and I said the target moves from
Center to the left back all the way
center to the right and then back to the
center moves one degree of freedom so if
you plot it this is how the target will
look and then i showed the this scion
line shows the width of the target and
this dotted line shows the width of the
cube so if you see that that the target
stays within the width of the cube all
the time so the user are collaborating
and maintaining such that a target stays
within the cube on them then they are
moving this is just one trial from one
of my experiments so if you look at the
plot some of the interesting things you
can look is this is a time series plot
from one of my one trial of my
experiment here I have compressed them
into logarithmic scale to show the
histogram of the delay and then here is
like just a time series plot so you can
see that within the network within
national lambda rail the spikes are much
smaller and the delay values are almost
the network acted as mode all as well as
ideal network you know like because of
the gigabit network and then but if you
see the network to tell you which has a
to research networks one in Europe and
one in the US and also a transatlantic
link which is a bottleneck node so you
can see this is quite a few spikes heat
spike means there is a huge delayed jump
in a delay values and then similarly for
you bc 2 we found a lot of spikes so in
this spice translate to if you plot the
standard deviation right this sign I
deviation a much larger for delay value
for network condition that existed
outside of us gigabit network also here
I showed that even though I didn't talk
about controls perspective of my
research one thing is what will if i
said i transmit UDP packets right but
you are not you and then under locally
us you are locally your your
program is running a thousand Hertz
every every one millisecond you want to
query the new position but you may not
get the new person because of a time
varying nature of the delay you may not
get new UDP packets at every instant of
time which is one millisecond clock so I
used zero or zero order hold in my
system so that if you do if you do not
have any new data you just hold the
previous value until you get the new
update so here it shows that otha at
under the hertz transmission rate you
always have this zeroth order of pole
for every ten packets and also you can
see that it's very because of time
varying nature of delay it is very under
usually if you look at my publications
things you see a lot of plots like this
which shows like for example this is the
root-mean-square position error between
the copies of the virtual object and
then I have scheme one scheme 2 and
scheme 3 and then I applaud this plots I
with standard deviation values and then
the inference for the the real what what
this plot is saying like you can you can
show many number of plots with Lord of
this ball graphs but I also do
statistical analysis I do like repeated
measures ANOVA and then say if my
results say the error is for example if
you see the positioner is much smaller
compared to scheme to but then are they
statistically significant that is that
so I come to my conclusion is after I
get the data I also run statistical
analysis to say okay this is not only
the data analytically show
quantitatively showing difference in
values they are also statistically
significant one of the interesting
aspects i saw is even when i use this
research network if you see there is
more packets that get lost in the
transmission because with UDP there is
no guarantee that your packet will reach
so there is more packets that get lost
for the delay condition which is
corresponding to you chilly so because
of the transatlantic liquor
it goes through multiple backbones there
is more packets that get completely lost
but interestingly if you see that even
though I use UDP I have for few out of
sequence packets because i am also
interested in out of sequence packet
because if i get a packet right the
packet number is 100 and i am using the
packet number under and if i get the
packet number 98 it is no use for me
because it's back in time i am not going
to use the soil I just throw those
packets so there are far fewer outer
sequence packets but I got far more
packet that get lost in the beginning I
said I am very interested in answering a
particular question is the sapta
collaboration is possible using a
distributed architecture out of all my
results using the distributed
architecture I based on my experiments i
get i can i can do a global scale haptic
collaboration imagine i was doing back
routing packets literally and then back
so i was able to achieve a collaboration
with the error of point 5 to point seven
millimeters position errors and for the
transmission rate of thousand two
hundred hertz so most of the times this
amount of error error tolerance specific
or meets the criteria of collaborative
applicant that includes protoculture
prototyping or cad task so if your cat
task can tolerate this much error then
you can use that peer-to-peer system to
do collaboration task so that so that
you can always maintain coherence see in
the simulation and then i also compared
the performance because in all my
experiments i am not only testing the
distributed architecture but i am also
testing the centralized architecture so
the centralized architecture will give
the least position error but then the
with the performance I got using the
distributed architecture from point 52
points and millimeter is really
comparable to the centralized so if I
have to use it if there is an option
than I would use the distributed
architecture rather than centralized
architecture
this is one segment of the talk and then
probably I should stop here and maybe
stop for questions or should I go to the
second here
yeah so
yeah so one of the key is this is the
root-mean-square position error point 5
20 point seven it doesn't tell the whole
story mean because this is like a root
mean square value of all the errors i
calculated but there is also another i
have several objective measures i am
also one of the key objective measure is
the peak position at any instant of
thing watch the peak if the peak
position error is really large then
whatever you are saying that the
collisions and everything will come in
to really play so if you if you remember
the in the virtual coupling scheme I
showed where there is a direct coupling
with a virtual objects you can tune that
parameters such that it minimizes the
peak position that is what i did in
experiment so the peak position error
was very minimal but also in this case
the user one has a local collision the
basically user one when you interact
with the virtual object equalized with
the virtual object so there is one
collision for that there is also another
collision where the virtual object can
collide with any objects similarly in
another peer this you have to do the
coalition so that is one of the if you
do if you go to distributed architecture
then you are going to more number of
positions across different of each peers
that is one of the drawback of using
distributed architecture but you know
blah often times you get a very decent
sized computer that can tolerate or
capable of doing this coalition
deductions also for example there is lot
of research work that involves
coalition's of complex polygonal models
or voxel models one of them is developed
at boeing called walks mappoint sure
which can do with which as lot of
pre-processing but then at real time
many running simulation it can it can do
collisions and update coalition forces
or thousand Hertz because when you say
collision is kind of very generic there
is two types of coalition when this
coalition for visual feedback but in
this case of I ideally want the
collisions to respond a thousand times
per second so you really want a really
fast collision response
I am going to just talk about another
aspect of the my work which will be four
next 10 minutes and then probably I will
close it for more questions so when i
said i use the real internet to do the
experiment that is really cool like I
can go and talk about AI used real
internet my friends hosted this packet
reflectors then it's all my subjects
experienced real internet condition but
then if i add with the network
conditions are fixed right i am using
the academic gigabit network and things
i cannot force to route the package to
terry different networks or so but then
you might want to test your system at
the very low bandwidth connections of
them so if you are to follow my system
then you have to look for somebody who
can host the packet refresher program
that is connected to this low bandwidth
network then i can run the experiments
rather you would want to use a network
emulator in a laboratory setting such
that the network emulator is guaranteed
to provide many different networks may
network condition then you can just
instead of routing the package for
internet the emulated 3s various delay
condition then you can test the system
in this so part of during my second year
of my thesis work I just got into more
of networks aspect because I want to see
what can I do to create network emulator
so luckily like network emulated already
exists there many different flavors and
things i do not have to do anything from
scratch i chose to use this net which is
a very popular network emulator and then
the real good thing is the data i got
during the internet experiment i can i
can input the delay the histogram of the
delay values in a emulator now i can
sail emulated okay recreate the same
condition so for example for a for the
packet reflector location in Italy if
for example if the server dies or like
if server is out for maintenance for a
week I don't have to wait for one leg to
continue my experiment i canno can say
if I am guaranteed to
create the same network condition a
laboratory setting then I cannot just do
it everything inside the laboratory so
basically this is the idea began me
using that particular in my experiments
so these are there are several
capability sike lot of people would know
about Network accumulators and then it
can create it can recreate various
Network conditions you can also make it
to change the bandwidth and then you can
greatly or you can mimic router
congestions and so etc etc on the as I
said why I need a network emulator
because I want to recreate various
conditions right lot of lot of times if
you see in literature people tend to use
a simple Gaussian model or very
simplified model for delay distribution
on delay generation but if you can do
that in a network emulated on and then
tested then you can convincingly say
that oh if my system performs so and so
and in this net this local network
condition then it is going to perform
the same thing when you actually connect
to a live internet or similar network
and also it gives a another one
important aspect is repeatability like
many scientific work you might want to
repeat recreate the same you got all
your experimental results should be
repeatable right if you publish a paper
and some graduate student in some other
lab does the same thing like me you
should get the same result as and what I
did so with network emulator you can
back again and again you can create the
same network conditions under but a part
of network which I was very interested
in the internet why I should use that
accumulated is because network condition
directly affects several key things one
of them stability as I already talked
about stability the honors ethering is
the tracking the tracking is very
similar to what i said in terms of
coherency so you want to all the virtual
objects to track each other another is a
force reflection one thing which I
didn't really touched upon in today's
talk is
one thing is maintaining the system
really stable the other thing is another
criteria like you know somebody would
say if you are in Boston and then I mean
CR that we are touching or each other
and then we are manipulating a robotic
arm and pushing say that there shouldn't
be really any difference if you are
located locally right just the delay
shouldn't change the way you feel the
force so that is called a transparency
in the system so your system should be
completely transferred transference
cancer it should be transferred the
transparency should be maintained
irrespective of the delay and often it
is a trade-off between stability and
transparency because you cannot really
maintain both you cannot satisfy both so
in my in my case stability is much more
higher criteria than transparency but
the network condition affects both so I
talked about most of the things in this
except that the work I did with network
emulator the application is not only to
the network haptic virtual environments
but it also applicable to cooperating
robots a multi-user multi-robot
teleoperation so I know there is a whole
group of people working on wireless
network simulation for bulk like multi
multi robot systems and so so it has a
direct application to many different
robotic Syria so I think it is lot
easier to show pictorially is like you
do this in the this workstation
maintains the packet reflector so you
send the package from ear to ear and it
routes back the packet then you collect
all the data right and then this is the
kind of the same global scale network
that I was using and it is very
interesting if you see for the delay
distribution locally that exists within
the gigabit network like national lambda
right you will see only two really long
spikes one is across the mean mean delay
value and then this the standard
deviation is so so less so always you
are expected your delay values to Clive
very close to the main delay value but
for the packet transmission that
across Italy is you often you see it's
significantly right tail because you
will end up that you you are going to
get lot of delay value over the mean
delay value as well as lot more delay
values which lies towards the right side
that is often when you see the packets
right you will see that you see some
packets close to the mean delay value
then suddenly you will see packets
coming at larger delivers and it's due
to the router fluctuation on there is
lot more factors that going to why this
distribution is like this so I I wanted
to recreate the same thing in a network
local emulator so the NIST net was
running in this box and then the two
workstations would just test to see
whether you can recreate the same
network condition now one thing I want
to stress is nested was completely
tested and every blood is lot of users
but then you have to remember that I am
using this net for a one specific
condition where I use UDP packets then I
want to transmit a thousand Hertz those
those conditions put very different
criteria on how the newsnet behaves so
I'm not going to go much in depth on
what the details about implementation on
my experimentation but because of UDP
packets of no you cannot maintain order
because you get out of sequence packets
and then there is no retransmission you
fear you snitch net and then to the
transmission thousand words you end up
lot more out of sequence packets but if
you really internet you do not get that
many out of sequence package you get
very unrealistic amount of how the
sequence pattern so there is already
people have experienced that problem and
then there is some solutions for that
one is to maintain clearing discipline
so that instead of arbitrarily placing
UDP packets in a in a queue you have to
place it such that the package that in
front of the few as two exit before you
can put something in front so that it is
artificial way of maintaining how does
less number of outer sequence packets um
one thing I really want to tell in two
slices I didn't stop just by testing the
mist net whether it can it can tolerate
thousand Hertz transmission rates for
UDP haptic transmission rates but I also
tested this with two users same
experiment process where all the
experiments i did with internet i also
retry to recreate the same thing using
the nested in a laboratory setting and
then i collect a lot of objective data
during the actual internet and then when
the subjects are doing the same
experiment using the m network emulator
then i get i get the same experimental
objective data at the end of the
experiment then i can compare these two
data the CA weather or they're very
different using this net and then using
the real internet they are very
different then maybe emulator is not a
good idea if they are very very close
are not much different than you can you
do not have to really use internet for
testing you can just use network
emulator so one of the key problem was
the emulators was giving too many out of
sequence packet as well as lot of packet
that gets lost in transmission is also
pretty pretty high in using emulator
which directly affected the performance
of the distributed and centralized
systems so i think i would stop because
the other is a very different topic i
would i would want to stop with this
conclusion about this experiment is the
emulator is suitable for lower packet
transmission rate what i say what i mean
by that is when i did my experiment i
also tested the emulated 43 packet
transmission rates one is thousand Hertz
500 hertz 100 Hertz so 400 Hertz and
find 400 Hertz it actually perfectly
matched the same same performance
measures I got using the internet using
unread hurts so for lower packet
transmission rates you can also see that
they kind of match in terms of our lost
packets to so for lower packet
transmission rates the emulator figured
very well like they
for for haptic transmission rates on
haptic data applications so if you are
using emulator then you can use it for
lower transmission rate 4,000 Hertz so
far i only tested listed as the only
emulator and it is not really suitable
for testing at towson hurts i think i
will stop my shop here and then open for
questions here
yeah so it's I can so I I think it's
more for example this is kind of a
discrete-time model the diagram I showed
was a mechanical model where you have
springs and dampers this is more a
controls perspective of what really that
here so basically you can derive a
input-output transformation for the
system and then you can define mean you
can always find the stability right you
can always find the stability and also d
is dis into the discrete-time system it
is also dependent on the sample rate so
I I I did that on my parameters like
when i said the springs right the spring
constant and damper values they were all
chosen such that the system is stable at
thousand Hertz so this this is something
it is much more interesting for people
who work a lot in controls perspectives
you can also look at it in a very
discrete time sense and then you can
derive very mathematically rigorous
input output system system basically you
have two inputs and then you also have
two outputs because I am interested in
positions of the virtual object and the
two users inputs are also position so
you can have multi input multiple system
and then definitely depends on the
sample rate so my system parameters are
tuned such that a thousand Hertz they
are stable and then that is that is one
of the I think I answered your question
here now so if you see that this is one
end and this is the other and two ends
rate both this hence locally they run a
thousand Hertz there is a local loop
that once a thousand Hertz but the
transmission rate varies as I said
thousand five hundred 100 so but then I
use is said I use 0 or 0 third or whole
to update the subject so that is locally
you will get a new information but then
the way updated the position using
zeroth-order world and then that's that
is why I have this transformation block
so when I when I incorporate stability
criteria it already includes
transmission rates that is why this is a
multi rate multi-input multi-output
system it's easy even though the that is
why I showed that figures with springs
and dampers because it kind of removes
the complexity of looking the system
like this and lot of times it's lot of
VC easier for people let us know you
connect the spring and damper between
two objects they go on if you push on
one the other is to move but then this
is what really controlled perspective on
that oh right now I do not have any
sadness primarily I am focused on
solving lift like the basic problem so i
do not i use UDP so and i should use
really higher higher number port but
then I don't know anyone can get there
done I have a publication which shows
the data structure to so but it's a
research so it is nothing very critical
it is happening but ultimately if you
have an application that involves
solidworks and then say boeing this
implement at this application and they
collaborate between two two locations
ultimately it needs to be really secure
so I am you might also also have to see
maybe different protocols so that it
supports secured transmissions and
things like that
one of them is the biggest challenge I
faced was you know like bowing at this
very very very nice application where
there is a fully full virtual
environment application that from CAD
models it has a completely aircraft
models and things and then to users can
collaborate on that when I started my
work I actually started building my
applications on that on their
application which involves among this
amount of source code and so many things
but then ultimately right I am trying to
solve the basic controls problem so I
really want to test something which
involves not that many lines of code or
say if we are to implement with code but
then it is conceptually also i wanna
test so i want to make my system such
that i know exactly what's happening
everywhere but so after i believe at the
six seven months after going through the
code and trying to make it work I said
okay let's go back to the drawing board
and say you know what this is not going
to work rather it's rather it's much
easy to create a very simple opengl
application having a simple virtual
object and then it's very easy to create
that right then but i have a complete
control of that because I I developed
the entire software so I know what's
happening in every functions and every
loops and things so now I can
conclusively say it may result is such
that i am a hundred percent confident
because i know in and out of my
application so I'd really learn to kind
of simplify a complex when you see
something it is really big but then if
you just slice through it and if you
just think through it you can make it
much simpler than you once you done so I
got the results right now this results
could be translated to the system but
rather if I try to test their system
based on my schemes I would have spend
much more at least one more year trying
to do that
it is called Norman Falcon it is
primarily the optic device is primarily
focused on gaming applications it's
called knowledge phantom so it is a 3
degrees of freedom force feedback and
three degrees of freedom input
and
you